ve lo ricordate granny non so se
conoscete granny non gioco horror sul
telefono che faceva paura fatto
benissimo ecco quel gioco ha fatto un
sacco di succedere lo cor gioca anche
mia nonna granny c'è veramente lega me
l'ha consigliata un altro così come ha
fatto un sacco di successo nel tempo
uscita altra roba alcune cose che
sembrano essere più [ __ ] però lo
vedremo solo scoprendolo no non era così
siamo ragazzi su il che significa in
inglese suona cattiva sora cattiva
ragazzi allora è un gioco per telefono
ma il menù è fatto molto meglio di un
sacco di giochi horror che ho giocato
nella mia vita
il che mi fa un sacco piacere let's go
com'è possibile che sto gioco è un gioco
fatto la telefono e alla traduzione
molto migliore di un sacco di giochi che
in realtà sono fatti per computer
complimenti tuo bambino è stato
selezionato per il mio bambino a pari a
ba via dante alighieri a bari da bere
alle sole the bay rea
dillo subito una trama un a scassare il
mio bambino e di bari ok
lei può provare può arrivare ovunque
devi sbrigarti a lasciare la scuola
beh questo che quest'anno sempre capito
a lei si riferisce alla prof di watt e
penso che dovrei guardarmi intorno viene
avanti ma che bella scuola
posso camminare usando il jolly fico che
ci quindi e tipo granny ho capito forse
potrei avere bisogno di rannicchiarsi ma
quanto fatta bene la traduzione isto
gioco mi inquieta un sacco la traduzione
fatta così bene rannicchiati ok è aperto
a ya no no perfetto permesso fino a qua
tutto bene ragazzi ancora non ci hanno
dato compiti o c'è una tipa salve c'è
una tipa che intrattenne una porta e chi
se ne frega io entro che c'è una tipa
che segue forte pulita dai sono entrato
non l'ho neanche visto in faccia non
l'ho neanche visto non vale non l'ho
neanche vista cosa vuole signor gatto
cosa vuole da me
salve tornando a noi sei sicuro di voler
tornare al menu declinare ora continua
riproviamo devo uscire da questa scuola
purtroppo sono quello che devi essere
buono sono lorenzo e starò bene non
l'avevo detto e questa cosa mi scusi
signora sora non volevo buttare giù il
quadro per me
allora sono in punizione c'è una
striscia di sangue
cosa ho fatta questa serata perché c'è
una bambola far cadere non o magari con
la bambola distrae la sua ora cosa che
devo fare qua ora questa bambola acqua
in teoria io la posso poggiare per terra
poi non so dove la la tipa più chiudi
chiudi prima di andare di qua magari poi
ci salviamo permesso anche se sembra un
po l'inferno col posto di prova dove la
suora in tutto questo salve sono un
bambino braccia è uscita quasi uscita
uscita ceco metallico aveva vedo che la
traduzione non è un cieco automatico
deve esserci un interruttore che lo
attiva nel senso che proprio lui non
vede non vede un serrando ceco c'è come
times osti ciechi o quanti c'è chi ci
sono mi scusi quadro se faccio cadere
quando ricava che frutta però è in forma
beh c'è la palestra 15 st mi sono pagato
un po sotto però ok meno male che non le
cuffie stato ragazzi mi spiegate come si
fa a stare in silenzio dove sarà
cacciato perché lei mi sente secondo me
anche se non ho ben capito come si fa ad
evadere da sta tizia prova messo
guardaroba posso entrarci nascondermi sa
cosa posso nascondermi finissimo e
sbirciare da qua ma è fatto benissimo
sto gioco succhia dai gli hanno
insegnato ad aprire le porte non avrei
mai detto
un orto o uomo e lavati i denti quando
ti capita no non mi butto cos'è sta roba
qua ma no non mi mettere la maschera
nella a queste scuole di bury quasi sono
difficili ma meglio possiamo trova da
scuola a lecce gioco finito beh comunque
simpatiche stesso ore molto bello
soggiorno riproviamoci ragazzi allora
allora riproviamo un attimo per vedere
come funziona questa comunque finora
orco demonio sono scarso sono il solo
qua sono qua solo qua sono fermo in
punizione rimango di punizione sono di
punizione ci rimango vice verso tocco il
ma cosa vuole ma è difficilissimo ma non
puoi non uscire piano c'è un bump anno
qua dentro lo prendiamo no nascondere
non ci nascondiamo promesso è chiusa
signora suora io posso uscire
va bene usciamo faceva il bagno delle
ragazze il bagno dei maschi prima mentre
in quello delle donne
lorenzo non è il bagno delle donne il
bagno mio è bloccato
c'è il mio bagno perché è in rosa il mio
bagno spiegami vabbè entrambi maschi
ecco perché mi hanno messo il mio nome
del bagno delle ragazze
il problema sembra che sia bloccato va
bè piscia lo stesso non sto capendo dove
sta andando la tipa posso passare qui
sotto posso molto bene pensare che fai
casino quando questa cosa luca no non è
vero non ci credo non ci credo ci fosse
sotto che è brutto gioco il viking
infilare dentro i cassetti
sotto tale sotto tale ma visto di
mortacci tua
e allora ho capito come ingraziarmi la
suora ragazzi c'è una tattica che io non
avevo ancora adoperato e pesta osanna e
usa nei osanna cristo signor tutti
insieme osanna e vedi che non puoi non
appare poi ricorda tutte le canzoni
cantava in chiesa di benedetto colui gay
nel nome del signor sala da pranzo fame
fame sete fame fame fame sete fame c'è
un topo c'è un topo qua fame fame fame
sete fame fame fame sete come lo magno
io c'è il topo nella bocca c'è il topo
nella bocca c'è il topo nella buca qua
grazie o signore che anche oggi ci fai
mangiare questo cantavo sempre io e
infatti non è servito in questo istante
farlo però che dove minchia sono caduto
dove maledizione son caduto spiegatemelo
do cos'era cos'era va bene basta la
canzoncina chiesa e che sono senso che
entriamo di sopra ero andato fino suo
sono stato bravissimo e problema che
dovrei farlo bene ti prego fa che non ci
sia di sopra di provare come accade a
chi idiota che deficente cosa c'é qua
sotto
c'è un cerchio stata questa sola qua non
è proprio una suora cattolica secondo me
cucina permesso
ma basta sto troppo ma cos'è ma pulite
ma c'è qualcosa si può passare
attraverso molto bene permesso non
buttiamoci quadri che tanto sono molto
belli se sento i suoi paesaggi passi
della tizia però non capisco dove prova
che finché non mi uccideva bensì
permesso gesù ma quanta sfiga possa
avere io da 1 a mille ci sono un milione
di porta entrata nella mia ce ne sono un
milione entra nelle mie porte gesù mi
chiamo vado con il crocifisso davanti se
non è possibile piano di sopra
allora vediamo di fare le cose giuste ho
votato su un quadro no quindi ok ti
giuro che se mi ammazza anche stavolta
me ne vado esco disinstallo tutto e vado
a giocare a briscola ma che guardare
chiuditi non ti chiudi quanti problemi
c'è un modo per fermarla tipo chiudere
la porta chicchi a porta a te io sto
cercando di sfuggire correndo perché se
no non posso
tutti dentro crisi entra niente mentre
ok perfetto in teoria anche in pratica
adesso non dovrebbero aggiungermi teoria
molto bene permesso ceco metallico
ammazzati c'è chi deve esserci un
interruttore che lo attiva va bene
allora torniamo su interruttore sì però
minchia non è possiamo questa questa
afferma dove vado io ma scusami ho
capito che era la suora sta ferma nel
punto in cui io vado cioè non è che fa
altro che va in giro sta ferma medievali
velista di sapere se merita si apre una
porta funziona è bloccata la porta
milito per forza entrare dalla botola
però prima di aprire la botola cos'è
questa cosa qua una manovella fermi
tutti forse serve per il coso di prima
come c'è un codice ma dai 666 immagino
ho fatto casino sorry
intanto mi porto qua dentro le cose che
magari sarebbe questa cosa qua capito
dove lo infilo sa fare ma perché c'è
anche una botola qua che non avevano
previsto
dov'è che vasta botola paciano e c'è
un'altra botola non ha dunque a quanti
posti ci sono gli storici stramaledetto
a scuola ammazza quanto è fatta bene la
scuola di bury a stavolta non i figli
stavolta te ne vai zia acciarello che
può andare di sotto però dimenticato che
è scemo cavola massa cosa orribile
ve l'ho dimenticato che poteva andare
sotto mamma mia che brutto no non posso
andare dietro questa che me ne faccio
gli stavano della stupida
cerco di a capire cosa farci però pian
piano dovrei scoprire cose continua a
correre qualcosa trovo c'è una manovella
io
spiegatemi dove la uso allora fammi
capire non il mit commesso quando metto
gli occhiali perché mi sto impegnando è
cosa che è successo qua si è sbloccata
la porta era già sbloccato a pane acqua
simpatici
[Musica]
questo non penso che questo non me
l'aspettavo così se manca impegnandomi
non mi sarei accorta quindi sono andato
molto bene rispetto ai soliti giochi del
genere non sono per niente ma non ho
capito come si apriva la cassaforte però
vabbè c'è sono andato molto avanti sono
soddisfatto perché gli sia piaciuto
ragazzi come se mi piace anche per i
soci a gomito tra descrizione sensi
d'aver cities chiedetevi noi ci vediamo
ma non possiamo vedo bene grazie
[Musica]